paris où cette 12e édition de l'écho du
cac it war se termine ce soir après le
dernier spectacle une très bonne
fréquentation cette année entre 1000 et
1500 personnes par jour alors avant de
clore cette édition je vous propose de
découvrir un spectacle nous avons vu cet
après midi ça s'appelle frigo de la
compagnie dit bonjour à la dame
vous allez voir c'est poétique drôle une
vraie surprise
qui a dit que les enfants avaient peur
des clowns pas de celui là en tout cas
frigo est un clown un peu italien un peu
triste un peu raté mais tellement
bienveillant le credo de frigo rythmo
energia magic
parce que forcément il faut un peu de
magie avec des bouts de ficelle très peu
de paroles tout en mime le clown
embarque le public avec lui dans toutes
ses facéties s'étonnant que les gens
participent autant qua non c'est sympa
et en plus il ya eu des sucettes
c'était très drôle on a passé un très
bon
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était un très chouette fidèles
ce qui vous a plu dans ce spectacle où
l'humour
on a cru jusqu'au bout et c'est un
italien et finalement c'était un
français c'était très sympa et wi fi
nalement frigo n'est pas italien il
s'appelle nicolas il est français mais
il à l'italie dans la peau j'ai appris
le métier en italie sur les routes
italiennes sur les bords de mer sur les
grandes villes italiennes et j'ai
vraiment appelé chez moi après ça là bas
ce qu'on appelait le théâtre de rue
sauvage vraiment en allant jouer au
chapeau dans les places et un jour la
petite histoire c'est qu'un jour ma
mallette est cassé et j'ai trouvé un
petit frigo à côté du véhicule ça
c'était il ya 18 ans donc c'est un
spectacle majeur maintenant la 18 ans et
j'ai remplacé la valise par un trio avec
tous les accessoires tous les objets de
jeu à l'intérieur
si le public français est moins acteur
que l'italien il a été conquis par ce
personnage très attachant le coup le
frigo a reçu une longue ovation cet
après midi sous le chapiteau de l'écho
du cac à thouars un joli moment je suis
de retour et cette fois ci avec lionel à
gallard maire de cheverny et co
créatrice de ce festival l'écho du cac à
thouars bonsoir pourquoi alors dites moi
le premier bilan là après le troisième
jour plutôt positif avec un public au
rendez-vous une thématique je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup séduit une météo un
peu capricieuse ce matin et cet après
midi mais qui ça y est le soleil est là
les finales va pouvoir avoir lieu en
voilà de très très bonnes conditions
voilà un public au rendez vous on est
vraiment très content vous avez eu plus
de monde que prévu je crois oui plus de
monde que prévu parce que ben je crois
que la thématique encore une fois très
très bien marché on a à peu près mille
deux mille deux cents personnes par jour
on attend verra ce qui se passe pour le
final mais ça s'est très très bien gérer
parce qu'il ya eu plusieurs spectacles
en même temps le public a pu avoir des
différentes propositions et ses
réparties sur les différentes
propositions donc volonté conditions
presque idéales
je crois que vous avez eu un coup de
coeur c'est le spectacle out un camp à
vue hier
expliquez-nous pourquoi ce coup de coeur
alors un spectacle très très original
avec du théâtre verticale faut imaginer
que la façade donc de la maison sur
lequel elle a eu lieu ce spectacle est
considérée comme la scène est donc le
spectacle se déroule en hauteur
avec de la poésie sur fond de bel canto
enfin voilà un très très beau spectacle
que j'ai vu à aurillac l'année dernière
et j'ai vraiment eu un coup de coeur et
je crois que le public aussi et là vous
avez un autre coup de coeur ce soir à
21h inventé comment ça s'appelle et
racontait nous de quoi ça parle
alors les robinsonnade du roi midas par
la famille goldoni
donc c'est un spectacle qui inspire et
de tout ce qui se passe autour de nous
avec la problématique environnementale
et quand on s'est posé la question de
cette de cette commémoration des 500 ans
de léonard de vinci etc
on s'est dit qu'est ce que léonard de
vinci essaierait de résoudre comme
problématique on aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'à l'époque il a beaucoup travaillé
sur le système hydraulique sont la
médecine sur aussi là les machines de
guerre sur les problématiques du vol et
on s'est dit que peut être aujourd'hui
la problématique environnementale le
préoccuperait il essaierait certainement
de trouver des solutions et ce spectacle
à las inspire vraiment de 2,2 machinerie
de pour essayer de répondre à cette
problématique
merci beaucoup madame le maire donc
c'est à 21h ici plein du chapiteau ce
sera le dernier spectacle de l'écho du
cas que toi votre soirée